us about how to understand random read
Solomon other large alphabet codes m
mostly read Solomon also random linear
codes yeah okay so some our Al codes
uh okay cool
um I encourage you
to like you can really feel free to ask
questions if I mean you do ask it's so
it's like it's not don't see this is a
uh you're not doing anything wrong I'm
just saying like continue asking
questions is great um okay so we have
our types
framework
and okay
so now I'm going to take this so so so
as I said like there's the way that
AGL uh proved the theorem which
is uh so they worked directly on random
read salmon
codes um and I think
implicitly they have a types framework
which is similar to this
except uh I think you guys didn't uh in
your implicit types system I think you
don't um you don't have the row span as
part of your types that's the that's the
main difference between my viewpoint and
your Viewpoint I think um and they
worked on that directly I'm going to uh
for intuition to or not just that the
way I think about this is first uh uh
proving
that random linear codes uh achieve the
list decoding GV bound when Q is
large um and then uh somehow using this
ination to reason about read solement
codes as well I mean there's going to be
a reduction here um from read from
random linear codes to read
codes um yeah and I'll try
to uh when it's viable I'll try to
compare like the the my presentation
with the what appears in with what AGL
did and like
okay so let's fix a type okay so this is
going to be a type over three uh just
with locality three okay so we have
three
vectors and the row span is going to be
F3 to the N F3 to the N means that right
like if the rows span everything so
think of a matrix where right so you
have this Matrix with X1 X2 and X3 the
rows span everything that means that
there are no non-trivial linear
relations between X1 X2 and X3 so that's
like the generic
case and we
fix a sequence of
partitions for a type so you know in
this row uh uh X1 needs to be equal to
x2 in this row X1 X2 and X3 all need to
be equal in this row there's nothing uh
we don't uh we don't uh uh put any
constraints on equality and and so forth
okay
do
youan you're right this should be an
this should be an L that's the second
time I was caught with the wrong uh
that's that's an important one that's
the second time I was caught with the
wrong exponent in these so that should
be uh that's fq to the L not F3 to the
oh my
God yeah that's embarrassing yeah fq to
the uh fq to the three
um okay yeah thank you okay
okay
um okay we want to know for this type is
okay so so right so we're we're
implicitly now doing a union bound over
type so so now the question has been
reduced to the to we're given a type for
example this this is not a generic type
because there's an fq to the three here
but uh other so so it's like we also
need to consider types where there are
relations between X1 X2 and X3 but for
this example we're going to assume that
very none
um and uh yeah and we wanted to try and
bound the probability that random linear
code contains any Matrix of this
type um so first intuition is that how
many
candidates are there so right so there
are Q to the RN code words so they're
roughly Q to the three RN Triplets of
code words that are candidates here why
do I say roughly because a small number
of these triplets uh have some
non-trivial relations between them for
example the triplet X1 X1 X1 is
obviously uh obviously has a some n
linear relation so so so it's not viable
for it does it's not viable for for
being you know belonging to this type um
but almost every triplet of code words
that we take uh is GNA be is GNA have no
non-trivial linear
relations
um so this is the number of uh of
triplets
involved
um and now the question is okay so
what's the probability that such a
triplet or how many such triplets uh do
we
expect um to satisfy the partitions
these
partitions
so now that each partition imposes an X1
X2 and X3 it imposes some linear uh
conditions how many conditions uh three
times the times the the size of the the
number of partitions right so here this
is here the number here the the size of
Pi of the partition itself is three
there are three casses and really it
doesn't POS any condition here there are
there's one class so it really imposes
two linear conditions uh X1 needs to
equal X2 and X1 needs to equal X3 in
square um and here it imposes one
condition X1 needs to equal
x okay so we can Define the
degree of this
type as you know the amount of Freedom
that we have which is three RN degrees
of freedom in choosing triplet
minus the
amount of
um minus the number of uh um of
conditions and then if this degree is
less than zero then this is easy to show
by a first moment argument for random
linear codes in random linear code
there's probably going to be no Matrix
of this
type um in the uh in the
Cod this is specifically for a random
linear code this is not easy at all to
show something similar for say a read
Sol code but for Rand your code this
specifically this specific part is
easy
okay and now so so this is kind of going
to be the an the analog of I mean this
can also really be
um this is really the exponent of some
expectation okay so this is really if
you remember what we did in the previous
the classic types framework right we
looked at the expectations and we said
okay if the expected number of elements
of the type in the random linear code go
to zero then with high probability this
type is not going to be contained in the
code at all now the question is in the
other direction suppose that this degree
is positive Okay so
uh an
expectation there are many
triplets does that mean that with high
probability the random linear code is
going to contain such a triplet okay so
it's the same question we asked before
what if the degree is large okay this is
red because this is this like seems like
a bad thing why is this a bad thing
because we don't want to contain like
right like a good code does not contain
uh uh V tripletes because these
tripletes are bad so large
uh um has a sense of something bad
looming for us
so would there be a triplet belonging to
the type
T in the code so here's a pretty simple
observation there must be non-trivial
triplets in the code which satisfy
p uh non-trivial means not all
zero why is that because the
degree is really
um right so so we have the degree is
just like the number of sorry is the
number of degrees of freedom minus the
number of linear
constraints if there are more degrees of
freedom than linear constraints then
there are non-trivial solutions always
it's not ristic it's just a
fact
okay but that doesn't necessarily
mean um that the um
that there is a
triplet of the given type in the code
and why is that
because uh the row span it's not
necessary that the row span be fq to the
3 okay so it's possible to have and
we're going to show an example later
it's possible to have sets of like sets
of constraints like sequences of
constraints where we will have
non-trivial
um non-rival
Solutions but all these nonrival
Solutions are going to have some uh
non-trivial linear relation between them
and just to give you an example of what
can be such a linear
solution it's possible for example that
they're not even distinct so it's
possible that you know there do
exist
um do exist uh non trial solution but in
each of them X1 is equal to X2 which
really defeats the purpose right I mean
in our types we
always we're always looking for a uh tle
like we always look for tles of distinct
code words so so
if every if each of these non-trivial
Solutions has X1 equal to X2 then
obviously this is not really this this
is not considered as the type being
contained in in the code okay so what
I'm saying here like the take out the
the takeaway from this is that it's
possible that the degree is large okay
we
expect a large number of uh we expect a
an expectation we're going to have a lot
of elements of the given type in the
code um but in actuality with high
probability we're not going to contain
even a single one which is really the
same as what we had in the classic types
framework okay yes I mean doesn't this
even hold like the case that they're all
the same could that even hold when the
degree is negative so the degree is
negative
um okay all I'm saying about the case
where the degree is negative is that in
that case you're not going to get like
in a random linear code with have high
probability you're not going to get uh
uh a triple of a triple satisfying all
the constraints with no linear relations
between them yes you could get a you
could get a a triplet in which like X1
is always equal to X2 yeah that's that's
possible so but somehow the first moment
method can account for that or yeah
we're going going to like yeah we're
going we're going to be discussing
exactly that yeah
um like yeah you're GNA get an idea of
what this uh what this sort of thing
really looks like in random lar
code
okay so here's an example of what I just
gave of what I just mentioned okay so
here I put a list of constraints okay so
just notice that almost all the
constraints like the third coordinate is
not involved in any constraint and
almost all the in almost all the
coordinates uh uh Al all of the
coordinates X1 needs to equal
X2 so what happens here if the rate is
large enough then the degree can be
positive like if the rate is I know like
three quarters or something then just
because three is never involved like it
gives us a lot of degrees of freedom so
so so the degree is going to be uh
large however it's very likely that all
the solutions will have X1 equal to X2
uh because you know for example assume
that this is the only place where we
don't want X1 to equal X2 okay we don't
need them to equal each other
then any solution
here um would need to have X1 and X2 be
defer from each other by you know at
most I have a Hamming distance at most
one and we know that a random linear
code is probably not going to have
distance one so so in all likelihood
we're not going to get solution even
though we're going to get Solutions
because it's degree positive we're not
going to get Solutions
in which X1 is equal to X2 okay
um okay so we're building into like a
statement of what does happen Okay we're
gonna get like this pretty clean
statement that explains what what types
we can actually expect to see in our
code so next I'm G to ask what about a
type of this form okay so now again we
have some constraints a list of
constraints a list of partitions but now
um I want X1 X2 and X3 to satisfy some
um some non-trivial uh relation so what
non-trivial relation do I want uh it's
probably even written on the board right
yes I want 2x3 to equal X1 plus
X2 so now I'm looking for I'm the type
I'm asking about I'm asking about um
triplets that you know X1 plus X in
every this holds this needs to hold in
every coordinate here I wrote this
correctly I've c three yes okay um I was
afraid that this is going to be a
running mistake throughout the whole uh
presentation um okay so so I'm only
going to look for triplets that satisfy
this and now um what's the degree of
this type with this
additional um with this additional uh
requirement so on one hand we have less
degrees of freedom because we added a
linear constraint now we have two
degrees of freedom instead of B once I
set uh um right the first two columns
the third one is going to be
determined so that seems like the degree
should go down um so is this good for
anything like from an adversarial point
of view right the adversary wants types
to appear so why would an adversary want
to impose uh uh any sort of constraint
like this it seems to just decrease the
amount of freedom but it also it can
also decrease number of
constraints so why is that because note
that this relation in this relation
suppose that Z1 equals Z2 okay then like
or here suppose that in some coordinate
like this and this are identical so you
get like 2x3 equals 2x1 so XV equals X1
okay
so the constraint V means that wherever
Z1 equals Z2 Z1 is also going to equal
Z3 so that means that this sort of
partition one two 3 now becomes one
constraint instead of two okay because
one equals two already gives us the one
equals as well okay so what this does
like I'm imposing this V on one hand we
REM moove our n degrees of freedom on
the other hand we remove a number of
constraints how many constraints
exactly we remove that depends on the
structure of this list here if there are
many uh constraints that look like this
1 2 3 then the number of constraints has
went down considerably possibly more
than the amount of degrees that we lost
okay so the degree the the the thing is
that the degree of this type it may
considerably it can be larger than the
degree of the type without this position
of v and it can be smaller both are
possible
okay um and this is just
formally uh saying what would be the
number of degrees of freedom that we
have now right so in general if we want
the row span to consist uh to like if
want to impose the row Span needs to be
V but the number of degrees of freedom
that we have is the dimension of V times
RN so for example um if we impose this
specific constraint when the dimension
was two after imposing this constraint
so so we had the this was 2 RN
minus um right
so
when given that we are living inside the
space V okay then a constraint such as
say one two
three um uh how many uh how many what's
the dimension of the constraint that
actually imposes with v it's the
dimension of V minus the dimension of
the intersection of v and the
space of uh rows that satisfy this
constraint
okay and if in a specific case where V
is just the entire space if it's F Q to
the 3 then this would just be this would
be just sum of three minus the dimension
of
uh uh VPI which
is yeah we
good yeah we're okay sorry yeah it's
it's exactly yeah it's exactly what we
had uh when we were
uh uh when we originally defined this
I'm just saying that this uh notion of
degree uh uh coincides with the notion
of degree that we gave before for the
specific case where V is the entire
space okay so now I
can give you the relevant threshold
theorem okay so here's uh when a random
linear
code is is likely to
contain a matrix of a given
type so what we
want is for the
degree of this
type with
v um to
be
larger and there really needs to be a
small Gap here I mean I I always okay
throughout this entire talk I use you
know inequality constraints and there's
always going to be some plus Epsilon n
here everywhere okay but uh uh in order
for the probabilities to actually make
sense uh but imagine that the degree of
p with the constraint V is larger than
the degree of p with the con well like
with any sub constraint okay any any
further constraint on the relations
between X1 X2 and X3 need to have
smaller degree less degrees of freedom
if this is the case then we
expect uh uh a matrix of type PV to
appear and I'll try to give the
intuition for why this is correct okay
I'm guessing this is something you don't
see immediately right
uh
so maybe the the the the first question
should be uh okay so this is an if and
only if so let's start
with
assuming
that
degree p v is less than the
degree
of and here's what we're going to do
now
so do you
remember uh the
matrices uh okay do you remember in the
classic
framework uh we had uh we used the fact
that in order for the code to contain a
matrix it also needs like if right if a
is in C then you also have
AB belongs to C for
o and
fq
so we're also going to use that here the
way we're going to use that is as
follows so suppose that this is the case
okay and U I remind you that U is
a like sub is a proper Subspace of
V so take
B to B okay so so we think of this B as
a this um this B think of it for a
second as a as a linear transformation
from V to some smaller space okay
because we we we apply it to the vector
like like we apply it to the rows of a
matrix of this type so these are rows
that all belong to V and we apply it and
we are going to project them onto some
smaller space how exactly are we going
to choose uh B we're going to choose B
so that the
kernal um maybe to simplify things let's
assume okay let's assume that V I
realize that this is better um just for
the inition let's
assume that V is the entire space okay
that's that would that would clear up
something that may be ambiguous here
okay so let's assume that V is the
entire space but it works the same if V
is anything smaller okay let the kernel
of
B Be
U okay so so think of um
um so so so what does B
do B is going
to basically mod out
you from okay we have three vectors
we're going to look at them mod
U and
now the okay now we have the type of the
matrices ba of the matrices a okay so we
have the set of all the matrices
uh of the form AB so consider this Set
uh this new space let's call it
uh
TB going to be the space of all the
matrices
AB where a belongs to T yeah where T is
like this
type so we're just doing the same thing
that we did in the classical case okay
we're defining this new set which is
what happens to a matrix
here uh when we apply B to it when we
mod out U and the thing is just because
of the just because of degree
consideration because the kernel plus
the image equals the size of the ambient
space um it's going to
hold so this is also a linear space okay
and result Al like we can also Define a
degree for this type just as we defined
above we also think of this as a type so
so we can also Define a degree for this
and then we're going to
have that the
degree of
TB um is exactly equal to the degree of
T
minus the
degree like yeah the of t let's call it
the degree
of
P minus the
degree of p with the kernel of B which
is okay so the thing is that this
type its degree is exactly going to be
this degree minus this degree this is
what happens when you mod out by U yeah
I'm having no pun intended to type error
um right so
B might possibly be small be tall and
skinny if Little B is less than l+
one B is always going to have less is
yeah we always
yeah yes yes yes so
then the matrices that live in TB might
have little B columns Which is less
than yes I see but you just it has
little B columns yes okay so then you
said the degree of TB but you haven't
specified a partition it be the same as
okay so so so defining the degree of TB
is is so this is okay this is not well
def this is not something I defined what
exactly it means to be like it's not
defined by partitions it's it's a it's
it's a slightly um it's a slightly more
complicated structure uh but the point
here is that the number of I mean degree
here is still going to be um is still
going to be defined as the number of
degrees of freedom minus number of
constraints I mean it's still okay like
the intuition for what does degree mean
is is still going to be the same that's
going to be degrees of fre minus
constraints okay so the degree of TB is
going to be the degree of this minus the
degree of this so it's going to be
negative okay and that means that in
random linear code we are going to
expect there to be no um say think of in
random code we're going to expect like
that that this is going to have say only
the all zero solution for TB okay so but
if the only element of TB is the all
zeros then that means that every
Matrix a here in the code when you apply
B to it you get
zero but if there's okay but but that
okay so so there's some non-trivial
Matrix that when you apply it to the
rows of
a you always get zero that means that
the rows of
a satisfy some non-trivial linear
relation and what we wanted like we what
we what we
required here to begin with is that
there are no non-trivial linear
relations okay um so
this would be equivalent to the easy
part of the threshold theorem in the
classical case because it shows that
okay so having a degree PV less than
degree
pu means that with high probability uh
um PV does not appear in the random
linear code that's what it says uh the
other direction that if this is larger
for this for all subspaces this is again
proven by a second moment method which
is completely analogous to like it uses
this same idea and and and and the
second moment method and then completely
analogous to how we proved the classical
case and how bolash proved the case for
graphs it's all the same idea so that b
was q q just for like without loss of
generality or just yeah this is not
yeah it's just to Avo it's just to avoid
too much notation that's everything but
but this this would hold for every V
here okay and I just want to know that
in
particular right so
so clearly yeah clearly like the degree
should be positive right this is like uh
this is something we already said if the
degree is negative when we don't expect
this type to to belong to the code so
how does that work with this
characterization well this conditioning
in
particular uh implies like this
condition should in particular hold for
U equals zero but when U is just a zero
like just like the trivial
space when degree of the the degree of p
with the trivial space is uh zero right
if uh because there's no degrees of
freedom but also all the constraints are
trly satisfied so that would be a zero
here so in particular this condition
posits that the degree of p with v is
indeed positive which see this is just
I'm saying this a as a sanity check for
this condition okay so this is our
threshold
theorem and this also to compare with
the AGL work this is why I insisted on
having uh this V uh uh uh inside the
type
um yeah
okay
so
now we can use this uh this
um this
idea or like the this uh
characterization just like the easy part
of this characterization the thing is
that the easy part of the
characterization now is not that like is
less trivial than it was before like
it's not that obvious right that like
having this condition like like the de
PV less than de p u mean that PV is
unlikely to appear it's it's not as
trivial as we had for the classical
framework uh but once you have that it's
actually not very hard to
prove uh that random linear
codes achieve the G the list decoding GV
bound um so so so so we Prov this fact
this was already proven by AGL AGL uh do
this by so some part of the theorem is
by reduction to to to read Solon codes
or to the way they handle read Solon
codes I'm guessing this is an artifact
of the fact that you guys f a lot about
read Solon codes and then ended up
realizing that you can also do this for
random linear codes
um but we also use a key component that
we took from you which
is um the notion of uh I forgot initi
mean WPC
well or right was it
sorry we partition connected yeah weekly
partition connected okay so so there's a
combinatorial thing that you
do um which the way I view it is just uh
uh showing I mean in my view the I just
use this this EUR comor idea to show
that uh for every like that that if we
are inside the parameters of the listic
coding GV bound then for every
V ver exists and U such that this this
inequality holds okay so this uh I mean
so yeah the way you do it is you think
of it as something in terms of hyperg
grass but it end up
being roughly the
same okay so so so this is a theorem
that can be proven us using this
framework but can also be proven again
has already been proven another
way
um and then we have yeah before you get
to the reduction for the just random
linear codes bit so you mentioned
earlier that this sort of typ notion
works just fine for the list recovery as
well does this theorem also work fine
for Recovery as well fortunately no uh
that would have been yeah no if if if
that yeah this is specifically you're
right I I I I actually promised that I'm
gonna say for talk what doesn't work for
like everything I said from the
introduction of these new types up to
this point was correct also for list
recovery and you know all other
properties that you can express using V
types this doesn't
um that's comor stuff doesn't
yeah the comor stuff doesn't work when
you have like the thing is that in the
list decoding case you really only care
like for a given coordinate you only
really care about like you have a
partition but you really care about only
one set in the partition uh when you
care about multiple sets in the
partition um then
yeah you get a more complicated
combinatorial structure uh for which the
the the logic uh from AGL or yeah all
these papers doesn't doesn't work
anymore
um but I do I want to say that I haven't
yet given enough thought to trying to
reason about list recoverability of
random linear codes with this framework
so I'm really hoping that it can be used
to to uh uh say something more
substantial maybe just to to give some
idea about how much more difficult this
is we know that okay for list
decoding uh you really don't care what's
the field you just care about its size
uh whereas for list recovery we know
that list recoverability of friend
linear codes is harder is at least we
know that it's hard when the field is a
like is a power of a small Prime like
there's a difference there's going to be
a difference between uh a field size
which is a power of two uh and a
comparable size which is just a prime um
and and there's nothing in the current
methods that can take into account
differences like that um
Okay cool so this is one
thing um and then the second theorem
that we have this is the reduction from
random linear codes to random read codes
um so if we have a local identity
property so we now we're going back to
you know list coding and list recovery
and everything together uh so let P be a
property that's achieved by random
linear code with high
probability uh then it's also
achieved uh with high probability by
random read salmon code uh where the
dependence uh the field size is going to
have this uh is going to be like order
of n uh with some dependence on L which
is going to be uh it depends on the
exact property but it's going to be at
most like uh L
todl like for for list recovery this is
going to be L todl for list decoding
it's going to be like two to the L okay
um the reason for this difference is
that um for L decoding again we we don't
really care about the partition we only
care about one set in the partition and
vers two to the AL possible sets for
this recovery we care about the whole
partition so it's going to be L to the L
if you want you can make this
Al
okay
uh yeah okay so this is what we prove
I'm going to talk about this proof in a
bit just let's get a correl out of this
before uh so a random read Solon code
achieves the list decoding gvb
with Q uh I should have said with Q
linear in n and this is already being
proven in the AGL paper I'll say again
something that compares our methods
so um AGL uses a theorem called the GM
MDS
theorem um and what they
do in my point of view so they go over
all the bad types for each type the gmds
theorem tells
you tell me if that makes sense the gmds
theorem tells you for a given
type that there exists a read Solon code
that does not contain matrices of that
type that the manages to avoid that type
and then they do an amplification a
probability amplification argument they
show that if there's one such read Solon
code then most read Solon like with
overwhelming probability this is going
to happen for read Solon code and the
overwhelming probability allows them to
do a union bound over the number of
types at least this is how I view your
argument but feel feel to correct me now
if you think I mean like uh the jmds
them is used to like use it like show
that the instuction ages have determined
symbolically non zero so you short
simple on that yeah you justed feel out
like you move like rows and you get a
bunch of determinants and each one you
apply shorts want yeah prob multip yeah
like the way you use it I think why
theer is not zero because there exists
one code which is good for that type
right yeah exactly yeah okay
so some determinate po just
sybol yeah so I I see this is a
probability amplification uh again
because because I think like you you
like you use the fact that there's one
good read Solon code and then you show
that almost every read Solon code is
good for that specific type but you need
to do it you need to unit over types
okay um maybe I'm
I may I mean maybe I don't understand
exactly like maybe there's a Nuance here
I'm missing this is kind of the way I'm
thinking about it um okay and we also
get that a random rment code is at least
as list recoverable as a random linear
code uh now there are many results uh
most of them have Mary's name on them uh
uh about list recoverability of random
linear codes um we don't think we have
the optimal one yet uh but if one day we
will then that will also immediately
apply to read salmon codes um another
question by the way that's been asked of
me here and I need to think about it I
don't have the answer on top of my head
is whether the this reduction also works
the other way around like can you reduce
from read solmon codes to random linear
codes because it's possible that there
are that's actually easier to reason
about list recoverability of read Sol
codes and then we can say something
about random linear codes given that so
so both directions here are uh
interesting I think our methods also
give a reduction in the other direction
but I'm not clear on that yet so so I'll
update whoever is interested later so
maybe I'm missing something trivial it
seems like if the list size grows then Q
grows is it because the Gap to the GB
band also decreases or something like
that um so the reason you need that is
because your local like I mean you need
Q to be larger
to um there are a few reasons you need Q
to be larger but I think the main one is
just in order to do this Union bound
over the number of types so you have
more types and as I showed
before uh the thing is that you allow
yourself a SL like the number of types
in order to un B number of them needs to
be like Q to the Epsilon n so the way
the because right like an Epsilon change
in the rate allows you to overcome this
number of types Q to the Epsilon n so
um if you increase Q this becomes larger
so you can do a union bound over more
types that that's that's really the
reason you mean this step back somebody
might say it's easier to have a larger
list size and the the answer should be
what that also no but it's also okay
larger list size also yeah but larger
list size also means that you that that
the bound or Arch changes yes if you if
you I mean increasing the list like The
Liston GV bound is not necessarily
easier with a larger list because it
also posits a better uh dependence of
the rates like better Gap to capacity
yeah obviously if you leave R the same
and only increase the list size then
yeah then you can just you know project
into the smaller list and you're
okay
okay uh okay so these are the results
and the time I have left I'm going to
speak a bit
about how to do this sort of reduction
okay
so um so using the threshold theorem
okay so what we know about random linear
codes really the problem that we come
down to is as follows
um so fix okay this should be like I
going one to end so fix a type okay fix
partitions
and we're only going to consider now
again the case where the where we don't
impose any linear constraints between
the
XIs uh but doing it it works the same if
we do imp post constraints okay with uh
for for just for this example assume
that we have a list of partition
constraints and we want to
know whether there
exists whatever exist in uh in the read
Solon code whatever exist l+ one
uh
vectors with that that satisfy these
partition constraints and crucially that
they do not have any non-trivial linear
relations between
them okay if they do have non nonrival
linear relations between them then
they're going to be counted under some
other uh uh right then they're not we
don't know to F2 the L plus1 here
there's going to be another Vector space
to that that will deal with separately
yeah those two should be cues
right yeah we should I don't think two
is at least I think all I think yeah
this should be fq DL plus one fql plus1
yeah I think all of my typos in this
presentation have to do with uh right
like with f something something it's
always like I think like four typos all
all in
the
subscript okay
yeah um okay
so
audience it's your fault it's all your
fault uh
okay um yeah giving a lecture is a lot
like parenting uh okay so uh never
mind okay so uh uh cool so so so so uh I
want to show that uh if the degree okay
so so okay the r the the the the
characterization for random linear codes
allows me to to to say okay if the
suppose that the
um suppose that I want to show that some
okay suppose that that I I I know that
some type is unlikely to appear in a
random linear code then that means
either that its degree is that the
degree is small of the type or that can
mod out by some Matrix B and then get
something something with small degree
okay so here I'm just assuming that I
already modded out and this is after the
modding out and then I have a type uh uh
with low degree and I want to show and I
want to show that if this is the
case um then uh a random read Solon code
is unlikely to contain a matrix of this
type okay and I want to play with this a
bit on the board now for a few minutes
just to give an intuition to how you
prove something like
that and I really think that
the crucial difference between this
method and what AGL do is that I'm going
to make heavy use of the fact that I
want that I only care about Solutions
like of bad tles that don't have linear
relations among them okay so how does
that work
um okay
so suppose a partition gives me okay
suppose like in suppose I have some
coordinate um in my code for which okay
so I'm going to have these tles let's
write them as a matrix have X1 X2 all
the way to x
one
okay so these are going to be
columns have Matrix of diena L +
one
n um now
suppose that the first
partition tells
me that the first two
coordinates need to
be
need to be
identical
[Music]
um
okay
so
okay these X1 to XL plus1 these are
words in read Solon code so they are uh
determined by some pols okay so let's
think of the coefficient vectors of
these pols um let's with some abuse of
notation let's actually let's confuse
the polinomial okay so these are going
to be polinomial P1 P2 all the way up to
p l + one of degree at most K of degree
less than k and I'm going to sometime
use them as polinomial and sometimes
increment them as coefficient vectors
let's see how it goes
um let's not call them P let's call them
just because I don't want confused it's
p
let's and now the first partition says
something like this okay so how uh what
does this mean it
means that five
one of
something must equal 5 2 of something of
what of some random field
element right because this row is just
going to I mean this is this row is is
corresponds to some random field element
so there some you know random Alpha Tak
uniformly q and F1 of alpha needs to
equal 5 2 of alpha and now doing this
abusive notation that I talked about I'm
also going to think about these
FES as
uh as uh coefficient vectors so this is
a linear constraint in these coefficient
vectors right it's going to be a
constraint that looks like uh 51 time
the vector 1 alpha alpha
2 need to
equal 5 2 product with the same
thing
okay
um now in
general negative
degree tells me that each time I okay so
so think of the process where I reveal
the relevant Alpha for each row and then
I add some more constraints about my FES
my five1 to five okay each uh uh each
Alpha I expose gives me a few additional
linear
constraints um and you know like okay so
specifically for this Alpha I only got
one constraint because the only
constraint by this in this partion that
one and two must equal but in general I
can get as as many as L concentrates
here it depends on the real of partition
now because the degree is
negative then you know if everything
goes well then I expect uh if everything
goes well I expect at some point to to
reach a a part where like where I have
so many constraints I have like I mean
my constraints should just like cover
the entire possible constraint space and
then there's only going to be the
trivial zero solution to the equations
that require the type to appear in the
code and then we're done okay if that
happens when we're done what's the
problem of course that during this
process it's possible that I
expose some new constraint that's
already implied by the previous
constraints and the question is how can
we avoid
that
um
so so we're going to do so so let's
start by assuming that you know I have
my set of constraints maybe I'll just
you're writing
here so suppose I already have like an
existing set of constraints let's call
it w are going to be my
constraints existing
constraints
on
51 to
5 + one and now I'm going to
add the
constraint of the
form
um let give name to these vectors okay
so these are going to
be let's say that V
Alpha Al is Q is going to be the vector
one alpha all the way to Alpha to the K
minus one okay so the new constraint I'm
going to add so let's say I'm adding a
constraint of the form uh
51 V
Alpha equals 5 2 V Alpha
um now it's possible that I'm adding a
few constraints at the same time and I'm
gonna I'm going to discuss that in a
second but for now let's assume that I'm
only adding one
constraint
so there's two things that can
happen one possibility is that I can ask
what's the probability that this
constraint is new okay that this is not
IED by the older
constraints one
possibility is
that
this okay so and okay what does this
depend on it depends on how many
constraints of this form are
already uh um spanned by the previous
constraints now here's the catch
if the the okay the bad thing that can
happen to me is that there are many that
that almost all constraints of this form
have already been spanned but what does
that mean that means that I'm extremely
close to the case where all constraints
of this form have been spanned if all
constraints of this form have been
spanned then that means that I have a
non-trial relation I have I have the
relation F1 equals 5
2 okay so either I'm very close to
having span
all constraints of this form and then
I'm done or I'm not very close and then
I just need to convince you that or even
I can even say more either I've already
spanned all these constraints and then
I'm done or I haven't spanned all these
constraints but then with pretty good
probability I'm GNA add a new constraint
that hasn't been spanned before okay so
if all of these constraints have been
spanned before I'm done because I I have
a non-trivial uh a non-trivial relation
between five between the FES
if
not then the space of constraints of
this form that have already that have
already been spanned it's not a full
degree so there exists some Vector
orthogonal to it let's call it I don't
know let's
U is
orthogonal cious
constraints
um and then this is going to add
something
new as
long as the V Alphas are not orthogonal
to you so we just need V
Alpha not your to you and this is the
sort of condition that we have well
sorry and this is okay this uh this this
okay so so like I have this I have a
certain uh linear functional U I'm
applying it to a random V Alpha okay and
we know that uh the V Alphas don't have
this is so this would be like uh uh
applying a r applying a certain
polinomial to a random Alpha and we know
that it's a low deegree polom the Pol of
degree at most case so we're not that
many solutions so the probability of
zero here is is is is small so we're
good okay so this is basically using the
fact that read Sol codes have good
weight or good or low bias uh to show
that when I add one
constraints um if I haven't already
added all constraints of this
form um then I'm likely to add the
constraint that's not implied by the
previous ones so that's okay but
this the only thing I use here for for
read Solon codes is the fact that they
have a good
distance so where do I need the exra
structure of read Sol code I need it
when I add several constraints at the
same time
okay so I could be adding like you know
something like F1 V Alpha equals 52 V
Alpha and also F1 V Alpha needs to also
equal 53 V Alpha and so on and I want to
make sure that all of these new
constraints I'm adding are new together
okay and then I'm going to need a
generalization of this to hold so what
generalization of this am we going to
need what do I have I'm almost done with
the proof
okay I'll be done so for example I'm
adding two
constraints and now I'm gonna vers
linear algebra that I'm not going to do
I'm just going to tell you the final
result it's going to look like
this there's going to be some Matrix if
I added two constraints it's going to be
a 2 by two Matrix there's going to be
this Matrix is going to look something
like this it's going to have um four
polinomial which are are determined by
the previously existing space okay so
these polinomial are going to be like S
one side two side three side
four and
size
green um
okay okay so I have a deter I have this
uh Matrix to apply it to some random
Alpha to apply all of these to some
random
Alpha and I want the determinant of this
Matrix to be non zero okay this is just
the case I showed you before is just the
case of a one by one Matrix so I just
want the entry to be non zero but in
general I want this determinant to be
non zero so I can assume that these
pols give a matrix like that the
determinant Pol of this Matrix is not
identically zero
um and then the requirement is that this
Matrix have non zero determinant when I
apply it to some random Alpha now the
thing is that the determinant of a b by
B
Matrix uh has is a polinomial of degree
at most B times the degree of the
polinomial so it has like instead of
degree K it has degree degree BK which
is still small enough if you know if I
took my Q to be large enough relative to
K
um and here I'm actually and here I'm
obviously actually using the structure
of a read solvent code um so so again
the the the conclusion is again going to
be that as long as I'm not already very
very close to
spanning all the uh linear relation like
to all to like to to already having some
linear relation uh uh be mandated for my
X1 to XL plus1 then um this is the event
that would allow me to make sure that
the new constraints I'm adding are
completely new okay so we just apply
that uh like we continuously
reveal the alphas corresponding to these
lines and each time we either uh get new
constraints uh added in or we end up
with some non-trivial uh or we end up
with some having already gotten some
non-trivial linear relation between
these X1 to X yes yeah I'm kind of just
curious about how to kind of make sure
during the your argument the determinant
is not
symbolically um
so you need to so so so let Let's uh
maybe let's take this offline because
it's
um you use the you use the fact that
there is at least you know that there is
if you haven't already exposed
all the um if you have okay the determin
is not going to be symbolically zero is
exactly for the same reason that in the
single new constraint case that I showed
you know that like we know that there
exists at least one possible vector that
like at least one possible Alpha for
which the
new um for for which the new constraint
won't uh will be new because other
otherwise you know that you already have
all the constraints and this is where we
use the the assumption that until the
current point the the there are still
linearly independent
Solutions okay um so just like this is
the this is the technique let's finish
with for recap of some open problems
that we
discussed um so I think we pretty much
discussed all of these brout I just like
wanted to list a few of it so yeah uh so
yeah okay we really want to understand
list recoverability better okay so uh if
we understand listability of random
linear code we're also going to get
something about listability of random
Sol code now um we want to break
the uh order of n Bits Randomness
barrier for derandomization ofand linear
codes um we want to be able to handle
nonlocal properties where the lists for
example list recovery with large lists
uh the list is exponential in n and not
a
constant um we want to handle what I
call Pi 2 properties okay so the for
example this toy problem with uh about
covering and one final thing I want to
do is I want to find uh let's I keep uh
putting this is my uh
this
is I want to find the limit objects for
uh code maybe I mispronounced the Latin
uh but uh uh so limit object okay so so
for graphs there is something called a
graphon which is if you take a sequ if
you take a random emble of graphs with a
grand graph emble with large n uh then
it's possible very classic useful result
to uh view these random graphs as
approaching some continuous object uh
which is very useful in trying to model
what happens with these random graphs
like instead you can it allows you to do
continuous operations uh like continuous
analysis instead of uh discrete analysis
to understand these graphs and I really
really like because these techniques
about like local stuff in graphs and
codes are really inspired by stuff that
happens in graphs I think it would be
amazing if we have something similar for
codes there's reasons to there's there
are reasons that this is this should be
considerably harder and perhaps
impossible uh but this is something that
I mean in my view this is something that
would be amazing if we love to think
about it okay that's it thank you for
bearing with me for three hours thank
you so
[Applause]
much thanks Jonathan for the great
sequence of talks we have a few
questions what what what if you think
about the linear code as kind of a k
graph and then that's your graph and
then sorry but if I think of linear code
as a k no because that's not what I'm
trying to model I'm trying to model the
geometry uh so I mean the geometry in
the sense of
um the geometry in the sense you know
distances between code words the K graph
won't give me that that because the the
K graph would give me like I for the K
graph I need some generators and the
generators are not going to be you know
E1 E2 and so on because then it's not
not going to be the generator for a code
it's or like for an interesting code
uh so uh the a is what average distance
list decoding right so did whatever you
say also say something about that or
just regular you're asking if the the
about random linear code yeah because
says that they actually a some average
dist decoding yeah I I think it should
also work for average distance
but not 100%
certain does it make sense to take like
gr up house tour I mean if you're
thinking about like metric properties
does it make sense to take gr house
limit of
family so you'd have to remind me I
think I heard the ter oning really have
house I I'll overall the and talk to
about it
later but it's a way to take a limit of
a sequence of metric spaces you look at
all embeddings of One
and
take currently I have no idea I need to
see the definition and think about
it maybe from a high level question to
an Integrity one so in the last transfer
so your RLC theorem only required the
degree to be less than zero but I guess
the thing you showed wanted it to be
less than minus RLC also wanted the
degree to be like it's not exactly less
than Zer it's it's somewhat less than
zero but yes for the read Sol no I think
I think in the C theum you also need
some EPS just like throughout this talk
I I through these talks I in many places
I you know I uh yeah I hid some Epsilon
gaps okay last call for a
question great let's break for lunch and
thanks again
Jonathan back here at two